Cuál fue el centro de los discursos de
los mandatarios latinoamericanos Cuáles
fueron los mensajes que más sonaron
bueno el mensaje muy buenas noches
Valentina y a todo el público de otras
24 quiero uno de los temas que más
resaltó fue el tema del cambio climático
la el papel que juega América Latina en
esta transición energética fueron los
temas principales pero pues claramente
entre cada país pues se hubo discursos
que hicieron énfasis distintos el de
Colombia podríamos mencionar que aparte
del cambio climático y el papel que
podría jugar allí en Colombia por tener
la amazonía también se enfocó en los
temas de la lucha contra cambiar la
guerra contra las del narcotráfico las
drogas Pero principalmente se centraron
en temas de cambio climático y temas
también de inequidad de desigualdad que
estos son dos factores que amenazan la
democracia en la región el presidente
del Salvador nayib bukele en su
intervención reiteró que Naciones Unidas
es una plataforma obsoleta Qué impacto
real tienen los discursos de los
presidentes de América Latina en este
escenario Bueno realmente no es nuevo
esta posición no hay que olvidar también
que se lleva de hace aproximadamente 25
años discutiendo sobre la reforma a las
Naciones Unidas en especial el consejo
de seguridad de Naciones Unidas que no
logra representar las nuevas dinámicas
políticas del mundo porque no incluye
países relevantes dentro de la economía
y en términos demográficos pueden ser
nuevamente llamados a la bandera para
hacer cambios y más en situaciones de
cambio de orden que estamos viviendo
actualmente por la competencia con China
la invasión ruso ucraniana pero pero en
especial son discursos que no son nuevos
sino que por el contrario refuerzan ya
peticiones de algunos países para
cambiar la estructura del sistema
internacional y poder que esta
organización pueda resolver los
problemas de riesgos globales como el
cambio climático la crisis financieras
las migraciones entre otros temas
puntualmente el discurso del presidente
brasileño Jair bolsonaro estuvo muy
enfocado en las elecciones de octubre
Cómo se ve este movimiento del
mandatario cuando los más recientes lo
muestran estancado en la intención de
Voto sí Valentina
bolsonador se centró en un doble
discurso en presentar un Brasil que está
le está yendo muy bien con unas buenos
resultados en términos económicos
medioambientales comerciales pero
realmente la realidad política interna
de Brasil no lo
demuestrara hablaba unos temas que había
gestionado perfecto el Kobe 19 Pero pues
tiene nueva acusaciones por esa mala
gestión también no hay que olvidar que
el tema climático que decía que que
quería defender y que la amazonía se ha
mantenido desde que fue descubierta como
el mismo lo mencionó Pues realmente pues
no es cierto porque no hay que olvidar
que el presidente bolsonaro fue uno de
los que más ha insistido en poder
intervenir en la amazonía distinto lo
vimos en el discurso de Gabriel borich y
del presidente Gustavo Petro que fueron
discursos que están más en sintonías con
un discurso propio doméstico en donde se
hacen reflexiones internas de cambios de
situaciones polémicas en Chile en
especial por la constitu y en Colombia
que se hace un diagnóstico en términos
de la paz total pero también de las
consecuencias que ha dejado la lucha
contra las drogas